are you afraid of getting old no I don't  think so I'm particularly not these days  I mean you know kind of a remarkable  reaffirmation of of how meaning is agent  if I can make it tapering out there to  senior citizens everywhere it is to say  that the you know age is only a number  and if you are healthy and if your head  is in the right place and if you have a  steady stream of Viagra and yes in  cabinet yes  but I think most important if you know  if you take care of yourself have it in  a healthy sense and if your head is in  the right place age is really only only  a number and life is to be celebrated  it's all too short anyway and you know  the great sadness in life is the fact  that we're all mortal and it will come  to an end and I think we should live  every life or every day of every day of  your life with great anticipation and a  celebration of the very fact that we're  here and that is you know the blessing  of it all  [Music]